言ってる その分は嘘ではないんだから
そこでまたもうノリに乗っちゃって
こういうこのお神輿をやってると本当に神様が見えてくるんだとかね
というと やっぱりそれでちょっと一言葉付け加えたくなっちゃうんです
言われただけでもありがとうございますとか言うじゃない
私を説得させようと思っちゃったら
まあそこでぶん殴られますけど
まあとにかくまあ世の中のことはまあ言いにくい
まあちょっと嫌味みたいな話なんですけど
やっぱり現実とは言いにくいもので
まあこの場で言いたかったのは
この移植とかね そういうものにはこの仏教から言えば全くもう気にすることはないんだと
そういうことをして人が治るならば治ってもいいんじゃないかと
で それだけの話なんです
まあ時間はなくなっちゃったんですけど
そういうことかもしれません
で とにかく今説明した個々のセットがカルマから生まれるセット
で 原因比設心の 5つのセットと
我々の生命の清潔してくれる 2種類のセットと
それから人間の心活動している心が依存するよりどころにしている物質的なエネルギーのセットと
それからただ体の生きてる体というセットですね
その 9つがあのカルマから生まれるんだと
であんまり説明は詳しいんだから
詳しいんだから まあ一応飛び出したいところなんですけど
で この前 この心で生まれる物質のことを言ったんですね
心で物質が生まれると
物質はセットセットで生まれるんですね
ですから 心で生まれる物質は何ですかと探してみて
それにこのセットを入れちゃえばそれだけのこと
で 一つ説明すると これ 6種類ありまして
で カーウィニャティックというものがあるんですね
身標識と体で表現する
体で人に何か言ってあげる
そこでなんで別な物質とそれで扱ってますかというと
手でこっちおいでくださいと言ったら
その人の心が変化するんですね
私はこうやって手を振っちゃうと
それを見てる人の心の中である変化が起こりまして
やっぱりあっちまで行かなくちゃいけないと行動を起こしちゃうんですね
ですから 何かこちらに何か原因があって
エネルギーがあって そのエネルギーは向こうに行って
そのエネルギーの引き金でその人がここまで来たことになっちゃうんですね
ですから この体で表現することは別な意識
エネルギーとして見ているんですね
物質というのはおかしい言葉ですけど
別なエネルギーとして見ているだけのことで
別にあるわけじゃないんです
そこで体で表現する場合は
この俯瞰別の 8はどうしても必要なんですね
それに表現という身をもって表現するということは入っちゃうんですね
そうすると 9つなんですね
そのセットの中で地水火風と色声味臭触と身標識と
その 9つ入っちゃうんです
だから私は手であっち行ってください
こっち来てください 違いますよという場合は
その 9つの物質が生まれるんだと
それはワンセット それで言葉で表現する場合を音で表現する場合は
言葉でなくてもいいんです
うーとか うーとかなんでもいいんです
えーとかね そういうのも表現ですから
その場合は地水火風と
あの まあ俯瞰別の8と音と
もう1つ入っちゃうんですね
なんでしたっけ？語標識
そこら辺はそんなに言わなくてもいいと思いますけど
語標識っていうのは言葉で表すということで
何が違いますかね まあこれ違うでしょうね
例えば母父 何の感情もなく言うとただの音なんですね
例えば私は他のもうラテン語の言葉でも何か言っちゃったら全然意味がわからないんだから
私にわからないんだから言えませんだけど
もうただの音なんですね
でも 例えば私はこういう言葉発声
今音を聞こえたでしょ？でも心に何も変化しなかったんですね
それは違う言葉で言ったんです
違う言語で ある言葉なの
ちゃんとした意味がある
ハッティっていうのは
でも全然頭の中で変化を起こしません
僕はそれを日本語で言います
象 象さんの象 そうすると何か変化を起こすでしょう
象と言った瞬間にもう象の映像が頭に入っちゃって
変化を起こしちゃうんですね
ですから 象といえばこの五標色
何か言い表すエネルギーと音と二種類があるんだと
と区別してるんです ハッティと言ったところで
もう今わかっちゃったんだからもうしょうがないんだけど
ハッティと言っちゃったら地水火風と
あの ワンナガンダラソウジャというやつと音だけなんですね
聞く人にとっては 全然心の中で変化を起こしません
でもドガンと言っちゃったら違います
例えば 私は自分の言葉で皆様にサカサニポコホザという質問する
それは質問なんですけど
全然反応ないでしょ その場合は九つしか色がないんです
地水火風と あの 味 香と
色 味 香と なんで 次にあの
地 音 それから音 サカサニポコホザという言葉の場合です
私はそれをちょっと違う風に言えば
元気ですかと 違うでしょ
その場合は 反応は違うんですね
元気ですか？というのは
だから私は同じことを言ってる
サカサニポコホザというのは
私の国の言葉でお元気ですかっていうことなんですね
でも反応はしない その時はただの音で終わっちゃうんです
お元気ですか？と言えば音だけでは終わらないんですね
そういうことで 五標色と音と二つとアビダンマで分けてるんです
ですから 言葉で音で表現する場合は
色は九つのじゃなくて十種類ですね
十種類九つ入ってるんです
かな と これは十種類ですね
十種類入ってるんですね
地水火風と あの 空いてる四つと
あの 音と五標色 そのセットで喋ってるんだ
だから我々は人と喋る時は
色は十種類のセット出してるんです
ずっと口から それは相手に伝わって
相手の心は変化していっちゃうんですね
手で 足で喋ってる場合は九つの色のセット出してるんですね
それで相手に伝わって理解できる
ですから このどんな国の人々にでも何のことなく手では喋れますね
通訳なくても 簡単に 言葉で喋る場合はやっぱり通訳
必要になっちゃうんですね
そうでないとただの音だけで終わっちゃいます
そういう物質のセットがここから生まれるセットです
まあまあ六種類あります
こちらには そこで次に行きます
全部六は説明しません
なぜかというと この前もそこら辺飛び出しましたから
ウトカラという自施設生受
それは四つ考えてるんですね
スッダッタカン サッダナウタ
そこら辺はね ここに説明しなくたっていいところですけど
うん えーと あの順番で勉強したならば
そこら辺はまあただ読むだけで終わっちゃいますよ
まあすぐわかるもんですからね
そうでないと これちょっと僕はややこしいところにどう説明すればいいかという問題にぶつかったんだけど
それであの あのウトカラあるいはあの火の元素から生まれる物質もセットセットで生まれるんだと
それから えっと アーハラ
地要素から生まれる物質もセットセットで生まれるんだということなんですね
だからまあそれぐらいの知識で十分です
あまりこのきめ細かく知らなくても
で 例えばご飯食べる場合はスッダッタカンという
あの地水火風の八つと
ラフターディエーカーダサカン
このラフターブーターカンマンヤタという
四つあるんですね いわゆる柔軟性とか何とか何とかという
そういうものは生まれてくるんだ
例えばご飯食べたら体が柔軟性が生まれてくるんですね
ご飯食べて楽になったと
楽になったっていうことは
この楽になったということも入れて
地水火風とかなどなどを入れて
寿命 老困も入れちゃって
まあそういう風な計算なんですね
だから 同じものなんです
そこで次に大事なこと
まあこれだけ言って終わります
四十一番目にはアッジャッタバヒッダカラアプと書いてあるんです
内と外との住 アッジャッタバヒッダっていうのは
内と外っていうのは 体にあるものは内で体と関係ないものは外です
そういう分析なんですね
そこは分かりやすいんです
体と関係ない いわゆる生命と関係ない物質は
もう建物やら椅子やら土やらそういうものなんですね
そちらにあるのは地水火風とついている色・香・味と地要素という八つだけなんですね
パトゥヤポーテージョワヨワンナガンダラソウジャという八つだけ
それは体に入っちゃうと老困入っちゃうんです
名色 命もあるんです 外のものには命がないんですね
その区別ですね それから音も同じことで
音の場合はどうやって音が生まれますかと
例えばスピーカーから音が出るんですね
それは外の物質なんですね
音っていうのは でも音は音のみ存在しない
音の中にも地水火風と色・香・味と地要素という八つもあるんです
私たちは全然音の色は見たことがないんだけど
人間には見られませんだけど
音の味もわかりませんだけど
でもわからないんだけど
あることはあるんだ 音の場合は音プラスあの八つですね
そうすると九つのセット
だから外にあるのはこの二つなんですね
外の世界には ですから
生命の中では他のセットいっぱい入ってあって
生命でないものにはこのセット二つがあるんだ
まあそれ それぐらいのことで
まあ世界のことを説明してるんですね
だから生命でない 生命と関係ないただの物質の世界は
あの地水火風と あの色と共にその八つだけか
その中から音も現れるならば九つのセットだけか
それだけで出来上がっているんだ
それに別にあの まあかなり考えていることなんです
例えば太陽にしたら 太陽には音はあるんですね
で 太陽に光もあるんです
それはもう光というのは我々に見えるということ
色ですから そういうのは当然ながらあるんです
だから あの物質だけの
だけの世界にあるのは二種類ですね
セット二種類 生命として見ると
またいろいろ働きがあるんですね
認識作用ですからね 別にある
まあそれ そこら辺で まあ時間は随分飛び出してますけど
止めましょう じゃあ大体そこら辺で色の方はやめます
で どんどん説明難しくなってきますので
あの あの心の世界わかってないと続かなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この色にはちょっと時間取りすぎでしたし
僕は色の二十八種類だけ説明して終わろうと思ってたんですね
で それどんどん組み合わせとか
あーだこーだと言い始めたんだからね
一応今日で色の世界は終わりにしましょう
物質的なイメージのこと
で 次回から心という方に行きます
さあ どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました